في حالة تأهب قصوى في البحر الأسود ، تمارس القوات
الخاصة الرومانية والبريطانية
مداهمة لسفينة معادية ، وهو
تمرين يتطلب الكثير من المهارة
ولكن أيضًا تعاونًا قويًا ، أخبرني أحد أفراد
القوات الخاصة الرومانية
بإدخال المروحية وإدخال
القارب بالتزامن  مهم جدًا حتى تتمكن
جميع الفرق من الوصول إلى
حدود السفينة في الوقت المحدد الذي يجب
أن يكونوا من بين وحدات النخبة في الناتو
وقد سمحوا لنا بالتصوير
بشرط عدم الكشف عن
هوياتهم ، حيث تتضمن الغارة نفخًا سريعًا صلبًا
بالإضافة إلى المروحية
لإنزال القوات على متن السفينة ،
فتشها واحتجز المقاتلين الأعداء المحتملين ، تعد هذه
التدريبات جزءًا من مناورة أكبر بكثير
للقوات الخاصة تسمى بصمة طروادة
تضم حوالي 30 دولة على حد سواء
حلفاء الناتو وغير الناتو
في مواجهة
لا علاقة لهذا التمرين بغزو روسيا
لأوكرانيا ، لكننا لسنا بعيدين جدًا عن
حدود أوكرانيا على الإطلاق والولايات المتحدة
كانت جيدة جدًا  ProjectSyndicate ar ولتعزيز تحالف الناتو
وإظهار التزامه
بالأمن الجماعي هنا في أوروبا ، تقع
رومانيا على حدود أوكرانيا مباشرة حيث تدور
رحى الحرب في البر والبحر على حدٍ سواء ،
جرت التدريبات على مقربة من
جزيرة الثعابين التي أغارها الروس
في أواخر فبراير / شباط الماضي.  احتلوا
الأوكرانيين رغم أنهم
ردوا بالضرب وتمكنوا من ضرب طراد المسكفا الرائد وإغراقها
في الأيام القليلة الماضية ،
ونشروا مقاطع فيديو لقواتهم
يُزعم أنها تصطدم بسفينة إنزال
روسية ومروحية روسية تفرغ
القوات في جزيرة الثعابين التي
ادعى الروس من جانبهم
لضرب طائرة هجومية أوكرانية وطائرة هليكوبتر
للقوات الرومانية تخبرنا أنها
اضطرت مؤخرًا إلى تدمير لغم بحري طاف
هنا من المياه الأوكرانية لكن
القائد المسؤول عن هذه التدريبات يقول
إنهم يبقون الحرب في الجوار بعيدًا عن
أذهانهم ويركزون على التحسن  إنه
مهم على مستوى التدريب
الذي تصل إليه ولكنه حقيقي تمامًا
الآن أعني أنه قريب منك  نعم ، إنه أمر حقيقي
ونحن مستعدون لأي
شيء تقوله الولايات المتحدة إن التدريبات مثل هذه
أصبحت أكثر أهمية منذ
غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا
لتقوية تحالف الناتو وردع
موسكو عن التحركات العدوانية ضد
الدول الأعضاء.